okay so hello everyone
thanks for coming so I'm Michael and
saying two things about myself so I'm a
PhD candidate at the ADH University in
Krakow at the department of computer
science and I'm also working for the
California startup which is using very
various AI solutions for for driving
assistance but today's talk is not gonna
be about safe driving with autonomous
driving it will be about quite a
research oriented topic that is
posterior collapse because it's research
oriented I'm gonna on his crutch over
the service so at the beginning I would
introduce variation allowed to encoder
quickly summarize it later I will
introduce the posterior collapse concept
I will I will show you how it manifests
later we will talk about what we can do
with this posterior collapse and then
the end some some further readings so
when it comes to variational auto
encoder so first introduced it in the
paper by der king by and Maxwell ink so
formally okay
this model is basic comprises so called
latent space and this latent space
contains some latent vectors and from
the model we are having a probability
distribution over this latent space it's
called the prior next we are having some
deterministic mapping which is no
surprises a neural network which encodes
this latent vector set into into our
data space latent it's called because
it's unobserved if we are learning such
models we are not observing in our
training data set this does that and
this is that effect our data sample over
the mapping F and this mapping F is used
to define generative probability of x
given that so basically as I told the
mapping is a neural network and if we
take the simplest case that our decoder
our generative probability is Gaussian
with identity matrix then basically our
neural network F and codes only the mean
parameter of
of search Gaussian obviously the
simplest choice off of the decoder that
is a Gaussian is not this is not fixed
one can use much more powerful decoder
for instance coming from autoregressive
family like like be gated pixel CNN but
but we will stick to the to the simplest
case okay and when it comes we can
easily generate samples from such
authoring from such model as I told we
are something from our prior we are
something latent vector from our prior
later we are using our neural net neural
network and because this is a simple
generative probability then basically we
are obtaining our our our data our data
sample but the name auto encoder is used
not coincidentally here so we besides
this generate this besides generator
besides this decoder we also need some
encoder this is something that is
mapping from our data space from our X's
into latent space into our zet and here
is the fool here is the full model of
variational auto encoder so here we are
having an encoder which is representing
so-called posterior probability of z
given x basically technically this
encoder is giving us the mean and
covariance parameters of the Gaussian
distribution because we are assuming
usually that this posterior has the form
of Gaussian later from these parameters
we are obtaining our codes that we are
so called to repair a metallization
trick but technically we are just
something from this from from Gaussian
distribution and at the end our decoder
is again mapping our latent code into
the into the observable space so
basically this how we are obtaining our
reconstructions so this is on the next
slide you have you see exactly what I
was what I am talking about so once
again if we want to reconstruct our data
we are calculating the posterior
parameters later latent code set and
through the decoder we are having our
our our reconstruct our reconstruction
reconstructed sample so okay now we can
move to posterior collapse so basically
I've prepared a couple experiments to
show you this concept and I for these
experiments I used so-called celebrity
faces dataset which contains small
images 64 by 64 3 channels images it has
over 200 K examples so I splitted this
dataset into the training 1 and test 1
in saturation so for training 150 K and
I created a simple variational auto
encoder with where encoder has a simple
architecture with basically after the
input we are having a series of 5
convolutions and non-linearity and at
the end i'm there is a fully connected
layer with 64 units in order to 32 for
mean and 32 for for covariance and
basically the coder is the inverse of
encoder were from this thirty two
dimensional latent code i'm i'm deriving
the the final the final of the final
object by by applying some series of
transposed convolutions okay now please
take a look at the reconstruction and
data generation so basically take a look
so this position corresponds to this
original image and this is reconstructed
one so in most cases some very basic
features are saved but definitely we
would like to have more more detail
deconstructions okay so now take a look
at the generation data generation so
again we are not here we are sampling
this latent code from from prior from
standard normal so and we are passing
over the decoder so as you can see
basically this reconstruction samples
look very similar to this generated
samples and because if we take a closer
look at particular examples for instance
Conan the Barbarian gets reconstructed
into something like this
probably you would like to have somebody
reconstruction and the other two
examples also very far from being
perfect so what happens here
although the decoder is giving us the
samples which resemble the our natural
face images
it's basically losing all of the
peculiar features of each particular
example so one can say that the coder is
ignoring the latent code which is which
is again calculated from the from the
original example and basically basically
for now we can introduce the the simple
definition of posterior collapse is that
basically the decoder the the latent
code which is which is containing which
is supposed to contain all of the
compressed features of our original
example that this latent code is being
ignored when during the decoding process
okay and in order to to answer why is
that we need to dig deeper how this
variational auto-encoders are being
trained so basically like in most waking
other neural networks we are adopting
so-called maximum likelihood estimation
procedure so basically we are looking
for such parameters of the of the neural
network here the neural net we are
having two neural networks encoder and
decoder so basically we are looking for
such parameters that the probability
assigned by this model is as high as
possible so basically it's summarized in
this in this formula but here's the so
okay from this model we are having prior
P of that we are having generative
probability so it might seem that we can
calculate the probability of our
training examples but unfortunately we
have to do the integration and
unfortunately we have to do the
integration over that variable where
this that variable appears in the
decoder very complicated way so such
integration is unfortunately is
infeasible so we have to
so you have to do something different
and fortunately we can introduce the
function which is tractable to compute
and for each of the parameter theta for
each example is smaller than the
original log likelihood and that's why
we are calling it a lower bound so the
full name of it is elbow in other words
evidence likelihood lower bound and if
this elbow is close enough to our
original data log likelihood then we can
hope that if we find good parameters for
this elbow they will be also a good
parameters for our original criterion
right okay and it appears that as I told
this elbow is tractable and it's the
formula for it it might look complicated
so at the beginning so first terms some
expected value later there is so-called
decay alter and this decay turn stands
for cubic libor divergence and it
measures the similarity between two
probability distributions and it appears
it appears that it met in in this case
it measures the probability between this
posterior Q which is modeled by the
encoder and between the prior and if you
take a look at them at this term
basically it's it's called it can be
caught like a reconstruction term as if
if it's supposed to be to be to be fine
if it's supposed to be big enough and
basically it seems that model has to do
a gut rec good reconstruction do the
good job in reconstructing our example
so basically from from the sample from
the latent code samples from this
posterior this probability has to it
probably has to assign relatively high
values of probability for the for the
original value axis in turn in case of
simple Gaussian decoder it appears that
this is a simple l2 loss between the
reconstructed value and the input value
so okay and let's take a closer look how
does this elbow how does this dkl term
facts the whole training process so
basically the encoder during the
learning is proposing some latent code
and without this dkl criterion it would
it would propose such latent code which
is lying in the space that the decoder
can conveniently reconstruct our sample
from and this decal term acts as a kind
of regularizer which is pushing this
latent code set into the priority of
that which again priority of that is a
standard normal wave which means that
this is mean equal to the vector of
zeros and identity covariance matrix so
basically it's pushing this DK is
pushing our latent code into the hyper
sphere sent Center at 0 with radius 1
and unfortunately in more in many cases
this dkl term is pushing too much this
our latent code so basically this latent
code becomes indistinguishable from
these samples from the prior and we are
saying that the posterior collapses into
the prior so this is the this is the
story behind the the central concept of
of this presentation and ok and why is
it a problem because take a look if this
term becomes very small then basically
posteriors that of given posterior that
given X becomes almost like a prior P of
that it means that this conditioning on
on that on X sorry
drops off so basically now the code
becomes independent of our data sample
which is very bad as we require from
require from our cue to to learn
actually the representation of our X
right so what we can do with it so the
first thing because in the original
elbow formulation there is this
reconstruction term and decay error term
but we can obviously get a simple idea
but honestly very
very useful that we are assigning some
weight into this dkl term so basically
we can vary how much to the our final
optimization criterion - how important
is this decal term and because because
when this term is too important then
this posterior collapse happens it's
reasonable to introduce better smaller
than one and when it better is smaller
than one then still this formulation is
still a lower bound as dkl gives us the
guarantee that it's non-negative so
basically here we are adding something
smaller with smaller weight and we are
still having an elbow just this elbow
which is less tight yeah when the beta
is greater than one it's this
dysfunction is not guaranteed to be a
lower bound but this is the other story
by the waiters this concept was
introduced in the paper but the model
better v AE and in this paper it
introduced in this publication where the
purpose of such model was slightly
different it was about learning this
entangled representation but this is not
this is not a topic of of today's
presentation but I strongly encourage
you to consult this paper ok so what
happens later
let's introduce better very small
something like 0.01 okay so 10 to power
minus 2 and take a look at the ID
reconstruction okay so definitely it
looks much better
thus reconstructing samples are much
more similar to the original ones for
instance let's take it or Conan the
Barbarian is here it's better than
previously but when it comes to general
data generation something like this
happens and this is no surprise because
if we are assigning very small weight to
our decay a term then usually this
latent codes are far from the prior and
we are we are generating data from this
prior ok by something zetz from prior
and later passing through decoder
so unfortunately data generations are
very very
very very poor okay so let's increase
into 0.1 so reconstructions are still
good but if you take a look at the data
generation it's better much definitely
far from perfect okay so let's go let's
go higher 0.25 still reconstructions
better than if beta is equal to 1 and
generation looks looks quite fine so
basically so basically the purpose of
this of showing you devolve the results
for various values of beta is that
although this concept of beta VI is
quite simple then for our data set we
can usually choose some reasonable beta
value that this that these latent codes
won't be ignored and still our our date
our generation process will will give
reasonable results okay so the next next
solution let's introduce modified
variation Alton Kirk so called vector
quantized via it was first introduced by
our own van der ort our own van the
world team
it's summarized in the paper Merl
discrete representation learning so here
basically because in the traditional via
e our that our latent vector is
continuous right this is for instance 32
values which are which are potentially
from minus to plus infinity so here our
that becomes discrete so basically here
our latent representation is a two
dimensional grid of discrete symbols
from 1 to K okay and how this model
works so at the beginning we have
encoder which at the end is giving us
some convolutional volume and here we
are maintaining some vectors which we
are calling embeddings
and here at each spatial position of the
of the encoders feature map we are
comparing with l2 distance we are
comparing how close this vector is from
from our embeddings and the index of the
vector which is which is closed which is
the closest one is being prescribed here
so for instance here it seems that the
closest vector to this one is e1 ok and
later during the coding the decoding
process what we have to do we are
preparing again the kind of 3d volume by
by doing the inverse by prescribing this
embedding vectors according to the
indices which are contained in our grid
set so here the vector e1 is being
prescribed on the input of the decoder
and later the decoder is some
convolutional architecture which is
giving us the final the final the final
example right now the question is ok the
question is how do we train such a model
so ok the first step we are using
reconstruction laws but if you look at
it closely then unfortunately it's
impossible to propagate greatly gradient
over that right because they are
discrete so you have to rely on some
tricks
so basically ok this loss function
besides reconstruction contains other
components which I will explain later
but here we are we are impossible it's
impossible to to back propagate
gradients on the encoders input so what
we are doing you're basically
prescribing the gradients from the
coders input into encoders output that's
the first thing but in this but but in
this in this scenario
we are leaving our embedding vectors
alone so basically we are not learning
them so the second term is responsible
for learning this embedding vectors and
we are doing it by bringing bringing
them close to the encoders output this
SG is States from stays for stop
gradient so if anyone basically during
the four-hour time it acts as an
identity function but it's but it
prevents from the gradients being
propagated through this note in the
graph we are talking about in the
context of this tensor flow so in tensor
flow this is TF stop gradient function
which is doing exactly this and also
this is the also this is there is a
third term so called commitment loss
which is oh by the way there is an error
it should be stopped gradient of e it
basically prevents this embedding
vectors to grow to grow too much but
what I strongly encourage you to consult
this paper ok so this is written ok so
we are applying some tricks in order to
train the model for reconstruction but
there is also the very important task of
data generation so what we can do with
it because that is discrete then we can
apply some very very nice machinery
which is which is called a family of
autoregressive models which originally
were developed to work over the pixel
space but basically they are leveraging
this property of joint joint random
variable basically such a joint
probability decomposes into conditional
product conditional probabilities even
we are establishing some order between
the dimensions of that and we can be
modeling such conditional probabilities
via CNN so this is the idea of of models
like auto regressive models like pixel
CNN
so CNN plus plus or pixels nail and the
nice thing here so basically we are
fitting such out the regressive model to
our prior that because that is usually a
grid of sixteen by sixteen then this is
not that pain because in general if you
are working on picture space if you are
working on images having the resolution
over 100 by 100
such models auto regressive models are
very difficult to train something from
it takes ages because we have to be
something sequentially pixel by pixel
but here is not that painful and ok and
where we are taking our data to fit such
a prior so basically if we already have
our vector quantized by trained free
construction laws then we can use it to
propose the latent latent samples from
our data set with this model so
basically such such such such Prioress
being as being fitted with with the data
prep processed by the encoder ok and
let's take a look at the result was
France to the reconstruction so
basically the original resolution 64 by
64 and I've chosen the the latent grid
to be 16 by 16 by 20 symbols so in order
to encode one of the possible twenty of
states we need only five beads so
basically the latent latent spaces is
quite small even smaller than the than
the original previously with latent
space equal to 32 and as you can see the
reconstructions are quite fine although
being quite blurry definitely the the
content of each sample is being saved as
as well as together with various
peculiar features of the face okay and
how about data generation so having like
this definitely some artifacts which are
undesired or more or less this
images looks quite sharp and some
samples are indistinguishable I would
say bye-bye
by human and the okay and the
architecture which I used for this
autoregressive I took pixel CNN
architecture with quite a big one so 12
layer 64 filters quite a big receptive
field remember that we are working over
data 16 by 16 so this model is quite
complex given our data and okay and the
final thing is the Delta ve were
basically what we are doing here we are
explicitly imposing a constraint on our
decal term
so our decal term is is guaranteed to
not to be smaller than certain volume so
this so this so this this constraint is
Delta and we are giving it from the from
the outside but unfortunately I was
unable to train this Delta ve the
reconstructions were and generations
were almost very similar to each other
so basically I'm not even showing it to
you maybe meant it's possible that
decoder is not was not sufficiently
powerful or or something like this okay
and here is Tom some further readings
okay and from my side that's that's all
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Michael for your presentation
we got a couple minutes for two
questions before the break so go ahead
hi thank you for your talk I only have a
short technical question because you
said you had two hundred thousands of
small images so how long it took you to
chain them on the side how many epics
and yeah when the training protocols so
basically because these are 64 by 64 and
I had the luxury of of having access to
Volta Volta visto vive hundred cards so
basically I trained for 60 epics I
trained for half an hour the whole
dataset so basically it was very very
very fast but but even not much much
less powerful cards it still will be
would be very fastest our encoder is
this is convolutional architecture
decoder is also the simplest one where
with single pass from each from each
latent code that we are having our
example with within a single pass so
this is very fast any other questions
okay so thank you Michael again thank
you enjoy the break
[Applause]